your apps performance is crucial to your
users happiness and your app success an
internal study of reviews on Google Play
found that half of one star reviews
mentioned stability or crashes
by identifying in fixing issues and bad
behaviors you could see happier users
and better ratings which will also
improve your apps discoverability
introducing Android vitals Android
vitals in the play console gives you new
data so you can understand your apps
stability battery usage and render time
on real devices
stability Android vitals include two bad
behaviors relating to stability
application not responding errors or a
NRS and crashes a NRS occur when the
application freezes and stops responding
to user input for more than five seconds
this is usually caused by deadlocks
slowness in UI threads or background
processes when your app crashes it can
be a frustrating experience for the user
impacting retention and leading to bad
reviews the crash rate will show you the
percentage of users experiencing crashes
in your app one way to address stability
issues is to run pre launch reports
which will test your alpha or beta app
on physical devices so you can identify
and fix issues before you launch
battery well-behaved apps don't consume
battery by keeping the device radio and
CPU on unnecessarily Android vitals lets
you see the metrics for two common
causes of battery drain wake up's and
wake locks wake ups are caused by alarms
performing time-based operations that
prevent an idle device from sleeping
wake locks are when the app has your
device working so hard it won't allow it
to sleep for better battery life you can
use job scheduling api's to schedule
asynchronous tasks and specify
conditions to maximize efficiency this
is suitable for small tasks like
clearing a cache and for large ones like
syncing a database to the cloud
render time the speed at which your app
renders impacts user perception of your
app performance slow render time or
frozen frames lead to bad reviews apps
that have a render time of 16
milliseconds or reach 60 frames per
second produce a silky smooth experience
for your users this is the rate at which
users can perceive smooth motion within
your app there for Android vitals lets
you see what percentage of users
experienced more than 50% of frames with
a render time of greater than 16
milliseconds so you can provide a smooth
experience across all devices anything
greater than a render time of 700
milliseconds it's considered a frozen
frame and at this rate users consider an
app to be unresponsive avoid slow render
times or frozen frames by using frame
metrics api's to measure per interaction
frame render times for devices during
production find out about other features
in the play console and get tips to grow
your app or game business with the
PlayBook app available on Google Play